he stood about three foot away from me
pointed again at my chest uh told me he
loved me and pulled the first trigger
Rachel's husband nearly killed her after
18 years of abuse she now supports other
victims of domestic violence but says
many women are losing faith in the
police
people don't feel safe reporting to the
police because of everything that's
happened over the last couple of years
what's the point in disclosing you know
am I disclosing to a decent police
officer or am I disclosing to a
perpetrator police officer in the six
months to last March more than 1500
police officers and staff in England and
Wales were investigated over concerns
about their treatment of women that's
0.7 percent of the entire police
Workforce less than one percent of those
investigated were sacked for articles
relating to the offenses in Saint Albans
in 2020 this this is the allegation
that's been made to us okay sir high
profile cases like met police officer
David Carrick who was jailed for a
series of rapes and Wayne cousins who
murdered Sarah everard have led police
to acknowledge that women have lost
confidence in officers we recognize that
the trust of women and girls across this
country is really really broken we want
to show that we are indeed shining that
light that we will continue to do so and
that we will do all we can to remove
people who shouldn't be working within
policing but we will do all that we can
with other parts of the system to
improve the criminal justice response in
leicestershire a new team of officers
are trying to change the culture it's
about acknowledging that using victim
blaming or minimizing language is
absolutely not acceptable but also that
sometimes it creates a barrier that
prevents people from feeling that we are
the right people to deal with their
complaints if trust in police is not
restored there's a risk women will feel
they have nowhere to turn Becky Johnson
Sky News